139 95 euro so die unverbindliche
preisempfehlung für den spielball der
neuen champions league saison die spiele
der königsklasse live schon länger nur
noch im bezahlfernsehen zu sehen
die champions league ist eben auch
spitze im geld machen
die einnahmen der uefa beliefen sich zum
ende der saison 2008 10 auf 2,1
milliarden euro
drei viertel davon mit
übertragungsrechten das meiste geld
davon fließt an die vereine mehr als
mannschaft dabei ist braucht auch jede
menge geld um mithalten zu können faix
oligarchen oder solvente
getränkehersteller haben schon einige
vereine finanziell fit gespritzt solche
klubs aus manchester oder paris können
sich dadurch transfers von über 100
millionen euro pro spieler leisten der
fc bayern hat sich zumindest in zwei
teuersten vom fc barcelona für ein jahr
ausgeliehen doch selbst der ruhiger
wurde es mit den millionen geschäften
der vereine zu viel sei 2013 geht das
financial fair play
dabei wird vor allem das verhältnis von
einnahmen und ausgaben eines vereins
gecheckt beide seiten müssen über die
jahre einigermaßen ausgeglichen sein
das geschäftsmodell darf nicht nur von
den riesigen investitionen eines mit
sense abhängen
trotzdem wurde wohl bei sponsorengeldern
leihgeschäften oder dem kauf von
spielern hier und da getrickst um die
offizielle gegenrechnung sauber zu
halten
bei verstößen drohen allerdings hohe
geldstrafen punktabzüge oder der
ausschluss von spielern oder des ganzen
vereins der große ac mailand darf in
dieser runde nicht auf europa ebene
spielen weil der die letzten jahre zu
viele schulden machte doch manche
finanzexperten sehen financial fairplay
eher skeptisch weil investoren so nur
begrenzt geld in kleinere vereine pumpen
können dadurch scheffelten in europa er
die erfolgreichen klubs mit den dicken
bilanzen weiter das große geld